Onto the world of JavaScript.
Concatenation here solves
two problems at once.
First and foremost,
it reduces a number of HTTP requests
needed to load your page in production.
Which is a big deal, especially
if you're on a mobile connection
with up to 300 milliseconds
of latency per request.
Secondly, it's the most basic
variant of dependency management.
You put all your script
into a folder and
instead of having to add script blocks
to load them one by one into HTML,
you simply add a single script
block that points to the generated
output file,
including all of them concatenated.
I say most basic variant because it
obviously isn't smart enough to detect
dependency chains and
the required load order.
But solving these problems
is a much harder task.
let's keep it simple for now.